okay this is from the daily wire it says
penguin random house canada
has contracted with psychology professor
jordan peterson
to release his forthcoming book beyond
order 12 more rules for life
on march 20 uh 2021
but the um the development has
reportedly also upset some staffers at
the publishing house
according to vice news which spoke to
four employees at penguin random house
canada
the publishing house held a town hall
style meeting where staff members aired
their grievances about peterson in the
upcoming book
some even cried about it they were
crying
about jordan peterson at work one
employee told vice that people were
crying in their meeting
in the meeting about how jordan peterson
has affected their lives
and noted that one person at the meeting
also claimed that their father had been
radicalized
by the self-help professor the employee
said the company since june has been
doing all these anti-racist and allyship
things and then publishing peterson's
book completely goes against this
it just makes all of their previous
efforts seem completely performative
in an interview with vice another
employee called peter called peterson an
icon of white supremacy
and as such suggested that the content
of his book doesn't matter
um okay a couple of things here
first of all you know i'm not an expert
in the publishing business but i do know
that the vast majority of books that a
publisher like random house puts out
don't make any money they make all their
money
from a few books that are put out every
year a book like jordan
jordan peace's book is going to sell you
know a billion copies or whatever
they make all their money from this and
so in other words
if these idiots actually succeeded in
stopping
their publishing house from publishing
jordan peterson a lot of them are gonna
lose their jobs
because that's how they're getting paid
this year is from that jordan peterson
book
and a couple of other books of course
they don't realize that because
they don't even understand their own
business because they're morons
um but but the other thing the main
thing of course is is um
this is just a good a good tip for all
employers i think
um if you have someone crying at work
i think and this could be a delicate
situation
best way to handle it is to you know
take them by the shoulder
lead them into your to your office if
you're the employer if you're their boss
and sit them down you know hand them a
tissue
and just and i would just and i would
just look at them very
with very kind eyes and say
get the hell out of here you
embarrassing baby
you're fired and then the next step the
next really important step is especially
if they're crying about jordan peterson
make sure to gather all of the other
employees
you know while that person gets their
box of stuff together have all the other
places stand
and just and as they're walking out
point and laugh as they walk out in
tears
that's the appropriate response to
somebody crying at work
completely unacceptable in general to
cry at work
over something like this especially so
now i did say this on twitter yesterday
and i was i was informed by some
women that um you know to have a rule of
no crying at work is unfair to to women
because
you know women have to cry every once in
a while at work it happens
and i understand that so i think what
the rules should be and i'm going to
talk to hr here at daley wire about this
but um because of course they care about
what i think the rules should be
so i think what the rule should be is
men you can never cry at work period you
cry at work you're done
and you're banning you're you're fired
and you're banished from from
all jobs in the future but for women uh
you can cry once per fiscal quarter
and so what i would say is plan ahead uh
just make it make it count
if you feel like you want to have
additional cries you can apply for a
waiver ahead of time with hr
and it'll take three to five business
days to process and when that comes
through you can have your
your cry so i think those were those are
what the rules should be
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated